what would happen if you started
consuming
omega-3 fish oils for 30 days that's a
topic I want to educate people on
because
omega-3 fatty acids are essential that
means that our bodies can't make them
but we need them and 70 of the entire
population is deficient in Omega three
and I'm going to tell you why they are
deficient and I'm also going to tell you
what will happen if you started putting
these Omega-3s back into the body and
you can do it through several ways fish
oils
fish oil is one way I prefer cod liver
oil because it also has two additional
things like vitamin d and vitamin A both
which are not in fish oils you don't
want to buy fish oil based on cost
because you're going to basically get
rancid fish oils and they're going to
cause more harm than good this is
because fish oils are highly susceptible
to being oxidized but of course the best
thing to do is to consume actual fatty
fish sardines grass-fed beef organ meats
and even eggs now I will mention about
you know like walnuts flaxseed hemp chia
seed might say they have omega-3 but
really they're precursors that turn into
omega-3 fatty acids they have something
called ala and then that can convert
into EPA and DHA EPA primarily helps you
reduce inflammation okay and a lot of
people have inflammation and you can
have inflammation in the joints so it
helps with arthritis you can have
inflammation in the heart so it can help
with your heart and then you have
something called DHA which is really
good for your brain in fact your brain
is made up of 20
DHA and I'm talking about the gray
matter the cerebral cortex this is why
fish oils are really good for memory
cognitive function attention focus
learning really good for kids yet many
kids don't consume fish or fish oils but
there is a reason why your parents or
your grandmother gave you cod liver oil
because that's more of a well-known
remedy for so many things that a lot of
the Nordic countries used cod liver oil
back in the day when they had long
Winters with very low vitamin D because
as we know we don't get a lot of sun
during the winter and a lot of people
become depressed during the winter and
they might have a worsening of their
arthritis so Collard oil is an excellent
source or just consume more fatty fish
through the winters now another
interesting benefit with cod liver oil
especially for kids if you can get them
to consume it is asthma and allergies
and it's a combination of just reducing
inflammation in the lungs I mean what's
an allergy it's like you have a lot of
inflammation but also the vitamin D is
one of the most potent
anti-inflammatories and vitamin D is one
of the most important things in asthma
this is why if asthmatic kids get more
sun their asthma goes in remission so
normally people take omega-3 fish oils
for heart problems or brain issues but
they are good for other things too so if
you consume them on a regular basis you
may find one of the following symptoms
disappear dry eyes now you can also help
dry eyes with vitamin A but also with
omega-3 the next one is dermatitis
especially if your skin is scaly and dry
and so when you're deficient in omega-3
you can develop what's called
age-related macular degeneration
affecting your site I already mentioned
all the arthritis both rheumatoid and
Osteo and arrhythmias in high blood
pressure another really interesting
benefit is improving a fatty liver
that's right by taking a certain fat you
can get rid of fat in your liver another
great benefit for omega-3 is increase
calcium absorption now of course if you
take the cod liver oil you're going to
get more calcium absorption because of
the vitamin D vitamin D helps you absorb
calcium by a factor of 20 times I notice
when people are deficient in calcium
they can have leg cramps but they also
have a hard time going to sleep easily
they might be tired but their head can't
relax or go to sleep in menstrual cramps
probably a combination because of the
anti-inflammatory effect but also the
vitamin D okay can help you absorb
calcium and actually reduce cramping
omega-3 fatty acids can also help you
with insomnia and even decrease the risk
of certain types of cancer now one
little problem that people have with
fish oils is the burping but they do
have them in capsules without the actual
oil okay so you can get them in capsules
you won't burp with those sometimes
people are allergic to fish oils or fish
or they might be vegan and don't want to
consume the fish well you can get
supplements that come from algae so
that's another source because the way
fish actually get their omega-3 is
through consuming phytoplankton and also
there's a simple simple test that you
can do okay just with one little blood
spot okay just take a little drop of
blood and you put on this piece of paper
you send it in and they can evaluate how
much
omega-3 is in your blood and give you
the ratios of something else which I
want to touch on next like omega-6 fatty
acids and I will put a link down below
of a company that will do your test and
I have no Kickbacks or affiliations with
this company now this next thing is very
very very important
take a look at this graph we're looking
at soy oil okay we're looking at an
omega-6 fatty acid what you need to know
is the omega-6 fatty acids compete for
the omega-3 fatty acids and I think one
of the big reasons why people are
deficient in omega-3 is not only because
they don't consume enough omega-3 like
fish oils or color oil but because they
consume too much of the competitor the
omega-6 which are is very very
inflammatory so that would be the soy
oil the corn oil the canola oil the
cottonseed oil the ratio of omega-6 to
omega-3 fatty acids really should be
like one to one most people are like 30
to 1 very heavy on the omega-6 fatty
acids but that test that I mentioned
will pick this up and tell you what your
ratios are one last point about these
omega-3 oils okay if you don't have a
gallbladder or you are deficient in bile
and you can't absorb these fats very
easily or maybe you have some type of
inflammatory condition in your gut you
may want to add some type of purified
bile salt as a supplement to start not
only getting more absorption of these
omega-3 fatty acids but also getting
absorption of the other Fat Cycle
vitamins that you need but I think we
really got ourselves in the situation
when we started to feed our animals way
more grains and getting them away from
the grass-fed food because animals that
are fed grains have significantly
reduced
omega-3 fatty acids than the grass-fed
and because we're on the topic of
nutrition and we're talking about
healthy foods there's a fascinating
study I was involved in some of the beef
that I raised on my farm to a lab and I
want to show you the results check this
video out right here